Daniel Cormier the first time
Jon Jones was probably main handles yes
but uh I had dinner with Steve Bay I
don't know probably three weeks ago
great guy he's absolutely massive is he
jack dude he's jacked like probably 255
260 like like yoked yolks like in the
firehouse just lifting weights the whole
time yo so for him man
uh good to see you Mr Anthony Smith
crashing at my man look at you dude
you're all over the place how you
feeling brother
I'm good man I'm just trying I'm trying
to get more checks without getting
punched in the face right that's the
goal man that would be pretty damn good
at getting punched in the face too like
you're one of those rare breeds DC was
another guy who could do it where
Donna Cruz
um you know where you can do the TV
stuff and the analyst stuff and the
podcasting but then still compete at a
very high level like not just like a guy
who's coasting you can tell they're one
foot in one foot out but I mean you're
you know top ten top five just a few
months ago like you're at the highest
level then also playing grab ass with my
dumb ass who's completely retired you
know
yeah I just don't want to
I don't know I don't want to have
nothing left you know like when I'm done
I don't want to finish competing and
once this Sport's done with me not know
what I'm going to do after that because
I didn't I didn't have a backup I had no
idea what I was going to do this was a
total accident yeah I don't think you
could get to your level where you know
you're a top five guy you're the tip of
the spare guy guys that fought you know
the Jon Jones of the world and those big
names and then have a backup plan you
know you can't really be that guy's like
well I'm just doing the UFC for now and
I'm going to jump over here into
entertainment it doesn't really work out
like that because those guys that are
half in half out you're not gonna you're
not sniffing the top ten so for you it's
just oh you got to burn the boats yeah
exactly you'll burn the boats 100 it's a
great way to put it I think for you what
makes you an outlier is you know you're
an articulate smart dude where Mo you
know we grew up in gyms man most guys
aren't like that like you articulate
well you've been in there just your
experience alone and the way you can
express that is what makes you an
outlier that's why it works that's why
you have a fan base outside of just
getting punched in the face
well I think it I think people can
relate because I'm just a regular dude
doing
extraordinary [__] like I'm just a I
live in a regular neighborhood dude I
drive regular Vehicles all my friends
are have regular ass jobs I don't hang
out with celebrities or yeah you know
like I don't really even know that many
other athletes that don't fight yep
um as and I just think that like I
didn't come through college sports
either so I didn't have like
you know I wasn't like a
special athlete doing something else
that switched over like you know DC and
Crews were fantastic wrestlers Crews was
fighting way early when it wasn't cool
um and kind of made that transition I
didn't really I didn't come from
anything Stu I wasn't good at anything
which is weird you say you're not good
but your your big athletic guy like
you're not small you're a massive guy
how the hell did you not get in sports
as a kid
I mean I played I just wasn't special
you know like I came from a real small
Nebraska Town
um you know I had 5 000 people in it so
like success there and nothing against
anybody that lives there still or that I
grew up with but like if you could get
one of the a job at one of the five
factories around it and work your way up
to a supervisor like you're making it
you know like you got the nicest house
and you're driving the new truck all the
time like that was success that's just
never me yep and I I think too what's
challenging not challenging it's good
too because you know good news or bad
news is always good you know it's still
getting clicks but because you are an
analyst your commentator you do the show
with Biz being who I love but you're
also you know again you're you're one of
the top contenders so when you speak
people listen so for instance I
co-signed this when he said this you're
like you know I'd be happy if this is
Amanda Nunes last fight I hope she
retires it'd be dope if she and I think
you have to walk through that fire to
appreciate her retiring and having her
wits about her she has kids you know
she's a family she's done it all and
even with Conor McGregor which we'll get
into but even with Connor I'm like I
hope he's done that'd be dope he you
tell me this guy has made it through
he's the highest paid athlete one of the
highest paid athletes of all time and
he's he has his wits about him he's done
oh man this is great I think being a
fighter we promote that it's like oh man
I hope that happens the fan base doesn't
understand that they want to see them
fight they won't see him get punched in
the face and eventually those people end
up like a BJ pan or Diego Sanchez so
when you said that I'm like yeah
completely agree but then I see the the
headlines and it's like they're like
almost mad at you I'm like oh these
people these are just riders or
journalists or you know people in the
game that have never fought they don't
understand this is such a great story
for Amanda Nunes but you got blasted for
it you got blasted for it oh I got dude
that's and that's the that's the new
thing these days is just kind of taken
out of context stuff that I say and some
of that is my fault because I just don't
give a [__] like because I live in my
own bubble like I'm here in Omaha
Nebraska like I I like I don't dig
myself super deep and I don't I don't
connect myself or how I feel about
myself to to like that side of the world
so like I've spent you know I I was at
the radio show earlier today I've been
by the pool ever since with a whole
bunch of people and we didn't take one
we didn't talk one thing about fights
and I come back in here we do this and
like it's I just I say how I feel and I
just kind of leave it you know and
that's that's what it is but I did get I
did see I got kind of blasted for that
and I don't understand how people could
be upset about that like
I guess the way that I looked at it is
she's got the fame she she doesn't even
want because she hates everything else
around like she hates the [__] that
comes along with the countdowns all that
stuff you can tell she's not right she
hates the inner yeah she's not into it
she hates the camera she hates the the
interviews the just the the circus part
of the show
but she's got all the money she's got
the record she's got the two belts
greatest she's got another baby on the
way she's got the houses the cars the
like for what like why do you keep going
because like
I I got a lot of cool [__] but I don't
have the records I'm not a
multi-millionaire like she is I'm not I
don't I don't have the belt so like I'm
still chasing that so I'm still like in
the fire yep but like what's the reason
for her to continue to go so like I say
I I look forward to seeing how happy
she's gonna be and people are like wow
you're looking for you know her demise
but then she retires
and she's in the Octagon running around
in circles never seen another kid porn
never pouring beer over her head never
and I think that validated your point he
was like yeah look how happy she is this
is exactly what Amanda Nunes wants to do
she owes you guys nothing she's given it
all she's done it all she's hands down
no argument the greatest female fighter
of all time it's over guys if this is
how you want their movie to end man we
don't want the end where she you know
she's you know slurring her words and
you know she's broken she has to fight
because she has to take care of the kids
and we don't want that and why people
advocate for that I have no clue again I
it'd be hard-pressed to find anybody
who's actually fought at that high level
in the UFC in the UFC just in general
that didn't agree with you I really only
saw I think other like journalists you
know and maybe some of the [__]
media Outlets go against your your point
of view there I didn't see anybody who's
actually made that walk disagree with
you I could be wrong no and I didn't I
didn't see too much of it either it's
just I don't know I just feel like I've
seen a weight lifted off of her
shoulders and just like a chance for her
to finally truly
relax and also the time you win you know
this I've never won that title yeah but
I would imagine that every time you win
the title or you defend it the next
thing that you're talking about is it's
who's next you never get to enjoy the
moment it's the same thing with just a
regular fight it's as soon as you get to
the post by press conference it's who's
next what's next next person you're
working a dates you look like it's
exhausting you've got small kids I got
small kids like I would love to just
fight sometime and have everything yeah
that I've ever wanted and like you
already got the titles and the belts and
the money and all that stuff and just
like sit down and be like [__] it like
I'm out I agree and I'm out and I'm just
gonna be home agree agree and and raise
my kids man and not have to worry about
things like she's one in every facet I
think two
you know one of the reasons like I
didn't do well with it because to your
point heavy lies the crown especially
when you're a title holder I remember
Ron is saying that like people don't
realize when you become a world champion
what that entails it's not only you're
just a UFC fighter but now the cards the
UFC is banking on you carrying the card
so if you're just whatever the first
find the main card you have some
obligations media wise but you're
they're not expecting you to sell actual
pay-per-views so when you're that
Championship degree that level the
amount of press you have to do all the
[__] non-stop it's exhausting heavy lies
the crown even Frank was like dude it's
just a different animal until we came
Champion it it wasn't that I didn't
enjoy fighting it just took the fun out
of it for me I was he was like I was
exhausted non-stop selling cards and
that's what I struggled with it's like I
remember beating Crow cop they put me in
the top ten my coaches were all
celebrating like your top ten I looked
and I went what snacks do nine nine
eight and seven are nightmares dude
that's what's next then what's after
seven six five four I don't want to do
that the reward is tough for fighting
yeah I mean your rewards getting your
ass whooped you know unless you're you
know unless you're a Jon Jones or some
[__] but it to that point no one talks
about it like it's I I always said it
like this it's like if you got a bull
and a bully in uh Elementary or Middle
School in high school there's a bully
you can navigate your way and you know
get away from them but in fighting it's
like that bully you can take a vacation
to Hawaii after one of your big fights
that you won you know that's your next
opponent it's on your mind 24 7. you can
kind of try and you know get away from
it but that bully follows you wherever
it's in your luggage wherever you go
some guys handle it great like you have
you've had a great career Conor does
well with it John's probably done the
best with it you know he can do all
sorts of [__] and still deal with it for
me it was so exhausting and the anxiety
I had in the stress I had all the time
it was such a relief when I was done you
know and so I think for Amanda to wrap
that up with Amanda it's like she must
feel such a sense of relief like not
only did I do it and I was able to deal
with all this pressure I did it the best
to ever do it and I have two young kids
and I have money in the bank I have Fame
in Brazil I'm Tom Cruise I'm good man
and it should be celebrated you had a
great Point brother
yeah I mean that's the great Point too
how people you just carry it with you
all the time like I always I tell people
all the time like training camps are
tough like physically yeah but it's it's
mentally you know especially now as you
get like higher ranked in the division
you know about these fights longer in
advance you know like I missed the days
of like four week notices and six week
notices you just train and go but like
now it's like 14 15 weeks
and you're doing like a lot of like
false starts where you're just trying to
like not get fat and totally out of
shape but like trying to you know like
trying to still enjoy yourself but like
you wake up and it's the first thing you
think about every single day and as
you're going to bed it's the last thing
on your mind like by the end of it I
[__] hate that guy and I don't even
know him it's just I'm so sick of this
dude
you're just sick of it dealing with it
man I'm over it's over man even the
fight like that I don't win or lose
let's just get this [__] over I'm
sick of thinking about this dude man you
know right it's harder dude and
especially in your division like light
heavyweight divisions getting pretty
crispy man like it was a little thin for
a while there right but now it's getting
like you look at the division you have
Alex Alex Pierre coming over there now
which will be a great fight for you
obviously he's fighting yeah that's
interesting
um how do you feel about Alex Pierre
going to light heavyweight I think you
when you look at before you answer when
I look at Alex Pierre
naturally 205 or big ass dude I think
that cut at middleweight was a nightmare
for him light heavyweight I figured he'd
always end up there his skill set when
you look at the top like eight matches
up pretty well for him not a ton of
Grapplers there's a few that we need to
keep him away from but you look at the
matchups like there's a lot of fun
matchups for him there I think you can
do Wells things to do well
I I I think he's gonna do well as long
as they match him up correctly and I
think they kind of started off on a bad
foot already to be honest I agree I I
think that yamahovich I think you take
Yon you take
a guy like Uncle life is a problem for
him can't fight him
I'm like and Clive you're out dude what
are you trying to do yeah we can't have
that you're injured yes you're injured
this ain't happening take a vacation
because he'll never beat Uncle alive
it's just even if you take the wrestling
out of it I still think Uncle life is
tough because he won't engage which made
it really tough for me I just he just
won't engage at all and like it's no
secret at this point like if you're a
good late kicker and you don't fully
commit to engaging in any like actual
striking exchange I'm gonna have a tough
time with you because I kind of need
that fire a little bit man
um I think that I think that he's if his
I think there's questions I guess what
I'm getting at that's fair if his chin
issues are a weight cutting issue
because he is sucking himself down so
far I think a lot of us know that the
more weight you cut the the worse your
durability is correct if if that solves
itself a little bit
um I think that he's going to do very
well if he has any chin issues at all
the problem at 205 especially right now
is there's some straight bangers you
boys guys that will they'll they'll step
right in the fire too it's like
heavyweight power with you know
middleweight athleticism yeah 205 it's a
funky ass it's a function yes
light heavyweight it's terrifying to me
terrifying twister Stephen Jamal Hill I
agree like even Jamal Hill will give him
problems because Jamal is one he is
he's so willing to fight he too he won't
he like he won't shy away from that
fight I guess is what I'm getting at and
two he believes in himself ultimately
which is its own kind of superpower
um and he's he's kind of tricky you know
like I've sparred around with Jamal like
you see it from the outside and you're
like man I feel like I could do really
well with that guy I can get to him and
then you get in there you're like oh
okay this makes a lot of sense like he's
got really good eyes like he's hard to
hit he hinges really oddly at the waist
what you would think would make his body
easy to hit but it's not
um and he you know he's powerful but
he's he's perfectly timed I think and
his accuracy is is right there so he
he's kind of a strange guy too I think a
guy like Johnny Walker is probably
Taylor Made for Alex Pereira because
there's no other threat I thought that
was gonna be his first fight I thought
that Johnny Walker was gonna be his
first fight like again to your point
Alex Pierre is his Reign at light
heavyweight is all going to depend on
matchups and the yawn one I was like not
to fight out give him if we want this
guy be a superstar Russell and and he's
tough on time is going to look very
similar to the arasania match-up
interesting yeah I could see that like
I've been saying for a long time that
young behovah might be the best kick
defender in the entire UFC across all
weight classes
um every every matchup that like big big
matchup that he's had in one has started
kind of with the late kick stuff Izzy
everything is he does starts with his
late kicking game he's got to kind of
establish that range in that distance
and he starts everything from the legs
up and he just couldn't get that going
with John and Jan was able to keep it
close enough striking to then end up
winning the last two rounds completely
by grappling uh Luke rockhold is very
similar everything is kind of based off
of his kicking game never got that going
started trying to wrestle and we all
seen how that ended so I think Alex
pereira's game is a little bit bass like
that everything kind of starts with the
late kicks and then he works his way up
which is trouble for yawn you know
trouble meaning if you're Alex Pierre
fan and like Yan does that really well
like this matchup isn't TaylorMade for
him and no and if Izzy can blast double
and knee tap anybody like Jan behovah's
absolutely can do the same thing you
know 100 100 and also we really haven't
seen Alex appear when you look at like
his come up in middleweight it was his
run was Taylor Made to get him to a
title shot yeah but he's got a good
manager yeah great manager Dana's like
we need a narrative with izz he's
killing everybody in top five sure so
let's get Alex bear up there at light
heavyweight not really the same kind of
easy test there man like when I saw Yan
I'm like ah definitely gonna watch but
other like a Johnny Walker fight for him
uh I even think Gary would be a better
matchup than Jan for him year year would
be a good matchup like even rakich is a
tough matchup mostly a striker but like
he can wrestle when he wants to yeah and
colliah just take a hike dude you're
gonna ruin all the stars we can't have
it you can't have it dude you know it's
like you guys that guy's tough yeah hell
yeah and not and not as big as I
expected to be honest with you he's one
of the smaller guys in the weight class
but yeah he's he's really patient too
that's a that's a especially if the
heavier weight classes you don't run
into guys that are agree as patient as
he is you know like he doesn't really
care about finishes he just he's just
there to not make mistakes yeah he just
which is tough yeah he just wants to win
but yeah light heavyweight is exciting
right now man with all the Conor stuff
going on you think uh I need your
thoughts on kind of I think Connor's
gonna fight so he I think the news is
what I was reading he has today to 6 p.m
to enlist in usada if he doesn't do it
by today by 6 pm he won't fight this
year
someone pressed Dana White like oh do
you think you know is Connor for sure
going to fight in Dan for the first time
which put down in my mind because I
thought when they had Chandler and uh
Connor's Ultimate Fighter coaches on
other for sure gonna fight can't have
him not fight they're it's happening on
big Connor fan I'm like this going down
and then at the press conference last
week someone asked Danny goes it's tough
to Wrangle these guys in when they have
money yeah like a guy like Connor a guy
like khabib it's very tough to get these
guys to fight I'm like whoa now again
I'm on the side of the fighters that go
good for Conor all the money has a
Lamborghini yacht doing his thing has
the kids good for him dude like right up
in the sunset man you've done it if you
have a Lamborghini yacht you don't
belong to hang out with us
what are you doing here some of us
aren't like the others man you know so
it's like he's just not he's at a
different level so when Dana and I I
side with Dana on that it's like yeah
man he's like when they have that much
money it's tough to Wrangle these guys
in so and if he doesn't enlist in usada
by 6 p.m we're probably like in the
fight this year I don't know if we see
him fight I don't and you see him
partying out there and you see Chandler
in his Instagram he's like working out
all the time it's like oh I don't know
something's going on here dude
yeah there's something going on there's
a reason
again another thing I got a lot of [__]
for was kind of questioning not even
really questioning Connor I was more mad
at the rule not so much Matt O'Connor
because of his whole leg break issue and
the reason that he's not in the pool yes
um I don't think that Conor is the type
of dude that was probably out there just
trying to dope and and just get away
with something we had a pretty wicked
leg break and if there was a loophole in
the system and he could use whatever
substances he has to use to to get it
healed like I think that that you saw
the list is a little bit it's a little
bit too narrowed in a lot of places so
there's guys that like Chris Weidman
could have definitely used a lot of that
stuff because he had multiple surgeries
trying to come back from his leg break
I'm sure he could have taken advantage
of a lot of that stuff
um but it was more just the the the the
no transparency with all of that where
it's like if he just came out and said
look I found a loophole and I'm going to
use it uh kind of [__] off and I'd
probably be like yeah I guess I get it
yeah whatever but good for you man um
but if he's not back in it it feels like
there's a there's there's another reason
you know what I mean like whether
they're worried about the system not
being cleaned out or or whatever
um I hope we see him fight but I
wouldn't be disappointed if we never
seen him fight again not because I don't
like watching counter fight I love
watching Connor fight
um
but again it's kind of like demanda
thing like why would you you I don't get
into belts all the money in the world
agree you got businesses and you got
small kids and like
man just party it up and hang out on
your yacht I I agree I get and then also
it's like they're talking about there's
an exemption that the UFC can grant and
they're only allowed like one or two
exemptions if I'm the UFC I'm pretty
transparent about it too like hey man
yeah he was off there healing his leg
we're gonna use the exempt on Connor the
other side of that is like would you
rather not fight do you want to see him
fight we're gonna use the exemption if
you guys can complain the other side
he's just not gonna fight so what do you
want here you care about the rules and
regulations are you going to see the one
of the greatest ever do it come back and
fight I would assume if you want to talk
everyone knows I agree one thing if they
came out later after like if Chandler
signs the contract and he wants his red
painting night like you kind of just
sign what like same same issue I had
with Jon Jones like I never criticized
John when he was like when he was uh
it's like failing like the when they had
the picogram thing going on pulsing or
whatever I never said anything about it
like it is what it is like I I knew I
knew all that when I signed the contract
yep like we we kind of knew the the
explanation or whatever whether you
believe it or not is is up to you but
there was no surprise now if it happened
afterwards and then no one said anything
that's when I would have been pissed but
like I can't complain about something I
knew about and then still sign the
contract oh green I think Chandler would
be the Biggest Loser here because Connor
sat when he fights or not he sat yeah
for channeling this wins or loses yeah
for channel this is his big night so I
challenge gonna be broken hard and even
Chandler goes I don't give a [__] one
test two tests six tests I don't care
just get into the Octagon so even
challenge
get him there give me the payday let's
do this so even he's like this man yeah
which I get if you're Michael Chandler
for sure like you just need your you
need that opportunity you like you can
work around all these other
out of the red tape you know especially
if he's aware of it and there's some
things that you're going to have to work
around but you know the opportunity
absolutely makes it worth it and then uh
knowing Jon Jones
um it's hard to gauge where he's at as a
heavyweight with that with that zero
gone fight we didn't learn much
he goes in there bullied dog you know
just basic choke and he's out of their
fight was a minute long we don't know
what John's like in there
um how do you see it going for John
obviously the the rumors steepe in
November there was some rumor of uh
Sergey pavlovich where I think he's a
very tough matchup for John you think
John has success like you did light
heavyweight heavy weight
no not the same not the same he'll do
well he'll beat almost every single
heavyweight out there
the the caveats there are pavlovich and
Stipe um the Stipe that fought Daniel
Cormier the first time
Jon Jones probably main handles but uh I
had dinner with Steve Bay I don't know
probably 30 weeks ago great guy and he's
absolutely massive is he jack dude he's
jacked like probably 255 260 like like
yoked yolks like in the firehouse just
lifting weights the whole time yo so for
him man
and he looks good like sometimes I don't
know sometimes you can tell when Stipe
is mentally around or not
so even around some of the even the
first two DC fights like he seemed kind
of like half and half out like he didn't
really give a [__]
um you know now he's asking me like me
and Stephen never talk about fighting
because he's just that guy he don't
really want he doesn't really watch
fights he's not even like a really big
fan of the sport no yeah but he likes
basically we spent the whole we spent
the whole dinner talking about fighting
techniques and wow footwork and movement
and I was like damn I didn't even know
you knew any of that stuff you know like
he's just not into it so mentally he's
he's focused for sure
um and I know that physically he looks a
lot better than he has in a long time so
he's definitely paying attention to his
his bodies lifting he's and I think that
that's smart like a 230 pound
that went in versus DC is going to have
a lot of problems with Jon Jones but
agree at 255 or 260 and fast and moving
and you know with his boxing on point I
think that's a tough fight and pavlovich
is absolute monster I'm scared I thought
he was gonna kill me one time why I was
he was we were on the same card and this
was maybe two or two fights ago of his
and we were in the back getting ready to
go to like the the ceremonial weigh-ins
and I I he was just like he's so [__]
big it's it's different when you're not
fat either and not fat it's just like a
big enough Russian and he's probably
wearing like a 3X just tight as [__]
around his chest and he's got this
translator with him this Russian
translator who I see it all the time
whether I'm working or fighting and I
you know I should have had some drinks
with the guy super cool
and so I'm like well I'll just crack a
joke because he's making me
uncomfortable because he's just staring
like right down the back of my head the
whole time so I was like hey ask him how
he's how come he's so [__] big and so
he just asked him thinking he thinks
it's gonna be funny
and pavlovich did not think of us at all
he just eyeballed me looked me up and
down and was like I eat I'm like okay
man all right I'm gonna get the [__] out
of here just trying to loosen things up
bro just trying to be cool man
he's just a scary [__] scariest
heavyweight there is right now and for
John dessert official Impressions yeah
for John to make a ton of sense of item
there's no huge option no besides
competition John probably beats him John
probably beats him he'd be a favorite
but but it's not gonna be fun but it's
not going to be a like a big seller
either no that yeah and that's the
that'd be the caveat there for John he's
like I'm not gonna make much money and
this guy's a [__] nightmare that
barely speaks and then sells Seven
pay-per-views unless it's in Russia so
with Stevie though yeah why with Stipe
I used to train with Steve a Savage
she's such a Savage great cardio my only
caveat when I heard he put on all this
weight is being have you when you put on
weight it's impossible to get quicker
and get faster when you're fighting Jon
if it's a slower version that's such an
advantage for John and by putting on
weight it's also impossible unless
there's illegal substance which I'm not
alluding to I don't Stevie would never
he's a firefighter for God's sakes he's
more American than any of us but with uh
if he puts on that weight we know cardio
is going to go down it's just the way it
works for sure so when you add the
muscle you add the speed factor and the
cardio it it to me like there's a few
alarms go off for me as a steepe fan
right one and
I think the one thing that may help
steepe there is I think that
John has probably again it's really
tough because we we didn't see a lot of
John like it was such an awful sample
size such an awful sample
but he in the in that short short sample
that we have he didn't look to move as
well as and that could have been a
little bit of ring rust because it was
out three years so like again there
might be other things that are going on
but he didn't seem to move as well
and he didn't seem as fast agree so if
steepe slows down just a little bit
he may still be faster than John and who
knows what John looks like over 25
minutes I agree that that's that was the
shittiest part I just wanted I didn't
really care who won
I would I wanted to see Sarah gone push
John striking and have his you know his
bouncing in and out style and forced
John to chase him just to see how John
moves because John has never been
he moves very well forward and back
he's never been a big angle cutter yeah
so I wanted to see if he if he could do
that cut off the ring that heavyweight
yeah versus the guy that he's because
everyone else is kind of circled down
outside the cage and John just kind of
you know keeps a you know you know keeps
the crosshairs on him and just walks him
down but you can't really do that with
Cyril gone so
um there was a lot I wanted to see with
John it just we just didn't get that
chance it was disappointing to for him
to go to heavyweights his easiest fight
in his entire career we learned nothing
which which kind of builds up obviously
we're we're
balls deep and fighting we want to see
more out of John but for the fans I
think it just builds John's narrative
even bigger and sells more pay-per-views
so see what happens on the way that Dana
talked about him at the post my press
conference too like I know that probably
deep down Dana was probably thinking the
same thing like damn I wanted to see
what he's really like because Dan is a
fan at the end of the day too for sure
but it was really easy to sit up there
and and sell John as the greatest of all
time and it just added to the you know
that already that narrative that's
already there y'all argue with the
equities look what he did to the interim
Champion okay just walked right through
him but I think us and the sport were
like [__] like I just want to see him
pushed and see what it looks like and
now what's weird is
you know Dana's talking about trying to
he's open to making a Jon Jones Tyson
Fury fight
which you know it you go down a weird
road with that stuff if they're gonna do
it like when Francis left uh the UFC for
the pfl
got great deal for Francis I think it's
a bad deal for pfl we'll see how that
works out in the future we won't know
for till a few years from now I'm glad
Francis got paid great guy
but yeah me too being a UFC die hard you
know I'm USA alumni I love UFC I bleed
UFC
the bummer with that is if Francis goes
on and fights Deontay Wilder Anthony
Joshua even Tyson Fury at some point
that the UFC is not involved in it
because for that to be a massive fight
you need the best promoter in the game
Dana White he needs to be part of it
like he was for Connor and Floyd that's
why that fight was so big I think if UC
is not involved that fight's not nowhere
near as big so with Francis going that
route like that's a bummer if he gets
those fights good for him but it's not
gonna be the same as if the UFC had
their hand in it for John the reason why
I'm open to it where you know it's
as quote-unquote a circus fight John
Tyson and the UFC's involved all right
now you got my interest now is he going
to get done highly doubt it I don't see
Tyson doing it it'd be interesting yeah
it'd be interesting yeah it'd be it'd be
great to
you know what else to add to your
Francis
uh I think everything you said there is
100 corrected it won't be quite the same
I also think that this talk about
Francis taking a
I don't know a tune-up fighter or a
warm-up like a boxing match yeah is a
terrible idea I agree awful idea because
that leaves the opportunity for people
to find not that you can't [__] fight
like as far as as far as boxing goes I
agree like he he's not gonna sniff a a
win with Tyson Superior Deontay wild
other Ortiz it's going to open them up
those guys are like we're good the cat's
out of the bag the narrative is right
yeah so even if you fight someone who's
technically better
but it's like a smaller middle of the
road heavyweight and he you know maybe
he squeaks out a win or gets a knockout
after losing most of the fight or
something not good they're never gonna
fight they're never you don't need any
tape if you do actually boxing before
you walk in there with the Deontay
Wilder or Tyson because they're not
going to take it yeah you're spot on I
have a buddy who uh works with them and
he go he runs stuff by me we always talk
about fighting great guy he's part of
France's team he goes wanna run this
bike what do you think of Francis just
you know get the get him in the
headlines if you fighting bare knuckle
against Alan Belcher
dude I was like
uh Francis and bare Knuckles yeah man he
just knocks him out real quick just to
get him in the headlines and you know
Fury and Joshua and Wilder see this and
want to fight him while I go okay cool
A's not bare knuckle boxer belcher's
been doing it we've seen with Mike Perry
moderate success in the UFC dominates
bare knuckle because it's a different
game the the the distance is different
the techniques are different it's just
it's a very ugly game I said so a he's
never done it you have no idea how he's
gonna perform I said and did your team
ever consider what happens if he loses
the pros and cons here if he were to
lose that fight you know what else is
different
Alan belcher's drug test correct that's
what I said [__] that's what have you
seen Alan lately first team monster no
dude he's on Monster I love it I love it
like that's another one of those things
like I'm I'm like totally against PDS
but like listen support bare knuckle
like I think everyone just kind of knows
like what whatever just run run what you
brung I guess yeah they're fighting with
bare Knuckles dude of course on PDC it's
like slap Fight League when they were
suspending guys I'm like what are we
doing here throwing rash guards I want
these guys on cocaine and steroids if
they're slapping each other for cocaine
I was like why are we testing slap
Fighters for cocaine I was like wait did
you don't give them cocaine if they
don't yeah they don't have cocaine you
need to give it to school they should be
suspended if they're not on cocaine you
know how do you feel about the slap
Fight League
uh I'm not a fan I think it moves the
ball backwards for the UFC I think
um God bless him and I think there is a
lane for it but I don't think Dana
should be involved in it I think he
should've been a silent investor and
helped on the outside and not get so
involved because the work Dana's done to
get to the UFC where it's at worth
whatever 14 billion dollars is on it's
insane the work he's done is God bless
him nobody else could do it insane but
when you go to slap fighting it takes
away because the lines get blurred and
when you're using the UFC's Twitter
account and Instagram to promote it the
Casual fans like oh wait slap fighting
UFC you know so I think it it blurs the
lines I'm not a fan of it and now I do
again there's a lane for it and I don't
hate on them good for them it's not for
me I'll watch it but I think where Dana
made the mistake is
he goes our our our Tick Tock numbers
are huge cool so if I'm on Tick Tock
which I'm not but if I'm on Tick Tock or
if I'm on I go to Worldstarhiphop and I
see an alligator eating a flamingo it's
cool to see for 15 seconds I don't want
an hour of alligators eating flamingos
it's cool to see yeah you know what I'm
saying it's like cool to see a guy get
slapped and then I move on with my day I
don't need the back story and their sad
story and you know they like to get do
cocaine and slap each other and get all
hyped up I don't think there's an actual
professional League there I think that's
what Dana's learning but Dana's a you
know he knows what he's doing so he'll
be able to make money and monetize that
you know but I just don't think there's
and he learned the hard way put on TBS
with an hour-long program I was watching
I'm like I can't believe they sanctioned
this we're worried about CT in the UFC
this I mean right we're seeing see I
think that's why I can't get enough of
it
I can't get enough of it bro I wish I'd
say enough of it bro
it's a car crash yeah I worked at a
Pilot event and called it like before
anyone even knew what was going on is it
cool in person
oh my God it's one of the it if you took
the top 10 knockout I've been I've been
fighting since oh six been at shows
working shows Cut men for shows been
fighting in the UFC you take the top 10
Knockouts that I've seen in person in my
entire career eight of them happened
that day
[Laughter]
dude it was the most insane [__] that
I've ever seen in my life and then like
you know you go in the back and and like
I want to meet these guys you know like
I watched a couple and we had a little
break and they're like you want to go
meet them and everything that you would
imagine one of these one of these guys
that would compete in this stuff which
you would imagine they were like a
behind the scenes like as a person yeah
they're exactly that and even better
like they're just [__] maniacs
they're Maniacs they're like
a couple of them made me uncomfortable
like this guy is [__] crazy this
guy's legitimately insane that he
belongs here though this is where this
is the only place that he's gonna he's
doing exactly what he fits in he's doing
exactly this is the exactly yeah dude
slapping each other in the face with a
rash guard on it's I it's so I don't I I
don't know like they don't really think
it's that crazy though that's the crazy
part to me either debate right like yeah
I'm like man are you guys like you guys
nervous like how do you feel like
whatever well they're pretty chill for
what they're about to do dude you
couldn't [__] pay me enough no hell
no and think about the guys we fought
the thing about the list of guys you
fought and someone goes you do slap
fight like I'm like absolutely not what
are you out of your mind it's against
someone that you've never heard of like
just that they pulled out of what you
know somewhere in Missouri
I was actually a fan of slap fighting
before Dana White even had the lap
League there was this like a small slap
fighting organization I used to buy
either internet pay-per-views oh you're
like a hard or fan dude yeah it's like
in Branson Missouri so I but I was like
a I was a closeted fan too because I
didn't want anybody to know like I just
watched it by myself on my phone at
night and then they just happened in the
call I was like oh the UFC's getting in
this [__] yeah I'm in I mean can I
invest I know I know all the best slot
fighters in the country there's like
Instagram Pages where they have like
these underground shows
and they don't tell anybody like they'll
put it on like some [__] you know
insta or some [__] pay-per-view
three pay eight dollars or whatever but
they don't ever tell anybody when it's
happening like live fantastic but they
have like pictures of like special
guests UFC fighter Anthony Spencer like
we're in like parking garages and [__]
dude you kind of make me want to get
into it now you also I think the first
like legit analyst like advocating for
it you know do you get [__] for it you
gotta know what it oh I get raked over
the clothes for it but it's like
I I don't know I just like what I like
like I think it's crazy that people are
I think it's crazy that people are so
upset that I like it like have you ever
watched me fight like I handed my
[__] tea to a referee in the middle
of a fight one time like they've got
your teeth you think it's weird yeah
yeah like you think it's weird that I
like to watch other people get slapped
like why are you so shocked yeah I think
I think for me I don't want people to
get twisted I'm not anti-slap fight
league right I'm anti when I put my
business hat I'm at like I don't see how
he's gonna make this a proper League you
know and I think I think a lot of us
have that that Wonder as well yeah but
as far as it would be entertaining I
don't know how you make a billion
dollars doing it yes but as long as
you're gonna do it I'm gonna watch you
fair yeah fair I think I'm very similar
I think I'm very similar to you like I
don't really care so much about their
backstories and their no you know like I
don't mind chilling and bsing with them
when I'm at the Apex or something like
there's there are a bunch of maniacs and
they're they're fun to hang out with a
little bit but
I don't really care about their home
lives and where they used to work and I
don't need the sad story
on the lady you know it's like yeah
yeah I don't need the whole setup oh you
know her car broke down she needs help
at this mechanic what's this big dick
you know it's like a slab fight just do
it man you know right yeah let's go dude
you've sold that slap fight again I'm
not a hate on SLAP fight like and I hope
it makes a billion dollars I you know
I'm not a hater on it I just did when I
watched for an hour now to that point my
wife couldn't stop laughing she loves it
she's like my wife loves you she's like
I can't believe they're doing this and
she's laughing the whole time like well
maybe there's something here because
there's something maybe my wife doesn't
even really watch fights that much I
should watch it here and there yeah but
if slap fighting's on like she's tuned
she'll have a couple friends over there
making Moscow mules and big ass cups and
because they don't want to leave
my Tuesday you're like what
yeah like I'll forget about it she was
like wait what do you want to do tonight
all right
that's hilarious you've sold me on SLAP
fight dude again I was never a hater on
it I hope anything the UFC touches does
well I think my issue was was the way it
was promoted through the UFC and the
UFC's worked so hard and people's put so
much hard work I never thought about
that blur in the lines thing that you
talked about I never I never even
considered that was my only issue I was
like if you just did it separate and it
was his own identity do that I'm and
I'll I'll ride with you but it got
blurry for me there and I'm like oh
don't do that though because if you're
looking at this guy was might not know
the difference that's that's my point
and that's that's where I get a little
scared with the WWE stuff where how far
are we gonna cross pollinate here where
you know my dad's like wait the
Undertaker is fighting you know Francis
and like what no Undertaker's not real
dad yeah you know so it gets it gets
blurry for the casuals
thing too where
there's already like a weird
I don't know Crossover with the fans
yeah excuse me Crossover with the fans
so
you know the the Casual very like flyby
MMA fans and the flyby WWE fans like
maybe they're only a fan of when Conor
fights and WrestleMania like that's a
weird that's a weird mix if you start
showing UFC fighters at WWE events and
WWE you know wrestlers at UFC events it
gets weird yeah because I just think it
takes away from the sport you know it is
a you know whatever the top five sports
in the world none of those Sports have
to do that and with the UFC doing it but
again I'm going to keep the same energy
where as a businessman yeah hell yeah
dude their evaluation goes from whatever
was 12 billion to 22 billion now you
know joining for it's a WWE I get it I
get what you guys are doing that's
making all the money in the world I get
it so it's hard to hate on it for sure I
just think yeah it's hard to talk [__]
about it it is yeah Dana's like what I
have seven private jets I'm like do your
thing man you know do your [__] thing
dude what's working and it's also I
totally agree yeah it's like with the
all have you been watching Ultimate
Fighter Ultimate Fighter fan
a little bit a little bit I had watched
it in a while like maybe the last five
seasons yeah
and so I've watched I've watched every
episode up till now it's it's
it's not terrible it the the let me ask
you something before you answer the
format is different let me ask you this
is it an outdated model because I can't
put my finger on what it is is it
because I'm the same with you when it
went to I think it was ESPN plus we had
to pay for it and you know it was kind
of weird and there was Dana White
Contender series which is much better
fighters on there and exciting fights
I'd always watch that so I got away from
Ultimate Fighter yeah then when Conor
came back and it's on regular uh
terrestrial TV and ESPN I'm like I'm
gonna check it out and being Ultimate
Fighter alumni I wanted to do well I
love the ultimate fighter and I'm
watching I'm like oh it's missing
something and I'm like is it just me or
is it is this kind of the the layout is
it outdated does this not work anymore
in 2023
I think it's just it looks too much of
the same I think like it's the jerseys
in the house and the like it's it's all
very much the same the jerseys are a
little bit different colors every time
but it's the same [__] yep
um I think what held me this one is that
there's kind of the Vets so I recognize
some of those guys that Cody Gibson like
and and some of the older guys had
already been around a little bit or
they've been in the UFC and got out
um or got cut or whatever like that's I
think that's what's hold me in because I
want to see those guys do well because
I'm always I'm always kind of rooting
for the you know the Redemption story
yeah the underdog the guys that you know
got a shot but didn't figure it out
right away and you're trying to you know
they're trying to have a second act I
guess
so I root for those guys but
I I don't know what it is it's it could
just be the format is just it just looks
the same every single season I don't I
don't know how you change that like even
the Ultimate Fighter logo is exactly the
same so it like it just looks like you
could move in different coaches and it's
kind of the same [__] agree and I think
writings are on your side there as well
like you see the rage not great and
there needs to be more Conor there needs
to be more concrete needs to be more
because I think that that's and I also
think it's hurting him is
and this is this is my issue with the
show and I had Laura sanco on and she
actually was opposed to my reasoning for
not liking the format
the Vets I'm with you I I like seeing
them have a Redemption story I don't
like that there's prospects in the house
I think you should be in all that house
or all prospects because the original
idea of The Ultimate Fighter was young
Talent give them a platform and then we
get to see their rise through the UFC so
when you have a young Prospect versus
guys who have been in the UFC and some
of those guys like the guy who fought
last night had seven of seven fight
Korean UFC went three or three and four
he's been in some big fights man he's
been on pay-per-views he's been you know
in some big ufcs he has that experience
and that's such an advantage to these
prospects who are wide-eyed bushy-tailed
don't have the experience the experience
you know it's better than anybody you
have more experience and damn near the
entire roster that experience is so
critical it's so key and maybe I'm
biased because when I was on The
Ultimate Fighter I had three fights go
in the house with three fights I'm
looking around I'm asking how many
fights you have Matt Metro and lied City
at three he had like two amateur fights
so basically had zero fights Domico
Rogers had I think two fights I'm like
looking around like okay we're all about
the same I see Roy Nelson I'm like in a
new fight I'm like is that Roy Nelson
but I can't like dude he has 30 fights
and he's a former world champion he
fought Ben Rothwell before he [__]
fought our dumb asses so I I was mad I
was like oh we're [__] dude I knew
from day one I'm like and I knew if I
got the finals he'd be in the finals
that's the guy he has 30 fights right
where we don't have that experience he's
gonna be able to take advantage of us so
maybe it's my own personal thing with
that but that's I'm like oh those poor
prospects and you see how it's going
Chandler's 3-0 it's not even close yeah
I mean I'm not shocked by that yeah
I told my guys I told my guys when I
walked down like I'm telling him Conor
screwed and I think that's one of the
reasons maybe the viewership's not as
high as Connor's losing every time and
it's not close
right I I figure I figured that the vets
were gonna be a lock overall are there
going to be some prospects that break
through a little bit for sure but
Chandler's not stupid and this isn't
just the TV show to him I think that's
part of the difference too is like this
is a TV show for ratings and and Conor's
just there to to play a position correct
Chandler's actually there to win like he
actually gives a [__] about winning the
show whereas I don't know that Conor
does I think that he's he's got a
different I don't know different goal in
mind you know which I totally get I
totally understand like like the
Chandler's there to win and
to those those vets they were this their
last opportunity and they know it the
prospects don't they don't know what
they don't know like they might lose
here they go on a regional scene they're
going to five or six five win streak
they'll get they'll get brought back uh
these veterans they know this is
probably their last opportunity and
they're and they're kind of looking at a
bunch of fresh meat that doesn't know
they don't know [__] about [__] yeah
these vets have kids and [__] it's like
you're fighting this young guy and I'm
like bro kids you're talking about that
dude's fighting for food dude you're
fighting for fame this dude over here is
fighting for rent big difference and he
has the experience and the skill set
he's been in big fights fighting at the
Apex Center ain't [__] for homeboy
fighting UFC 200 or whatever he fought
in you know right I so I just don't like
that because it well like worst case
these prospects they move back in with
their parents you know what I mean yeah
that's why I worked out yeah exactly
yeah yeah my kids don't eat my kids
don't get go to school so it's just a
different I just didn't like that I
think for the prospect they're at such a
disadvantage now Laura sanco had a good
comeback and that's why I like doing
these shows I'm anybody to verbally spar
with Laura saying goes well hold on
Brandon we don't know how the show ends
there could be a prospect who dominates
like we haven't gone through so there
might be some badass Prospect who goes
around to the finale and then they get
to UFC and we get to see the run you
like to watch but yeah fair I'm just
saying it's just fair when you look at
the the veterans
at the end of the day let's say in the
odds are on my side let's say a veteran
wins that show he's already been in the
UFC so we can't give him some young
young buck in the UFC who's never fought
in the UFC because this guy's he's had
seven eight fights already he's coming
off The Ultimate Fighter he has a name
we're gonna toss him in the top 15.
you're telling me you're throwing the
mix right away bro have to because he's
not some young Prospect who's just me
fighting on the undercards he has to get
thrown in the mix you tell me there's
the talent on that veteran list who can
compete with the top 15. I just don't
see a win for the UFC there
yeah yeah that's that that's a great
point because you can't throw in oh okay
I don't remember the kid's name in the
fight no not this last season not this
last episode but the one before
uh uh it's a black kid all the quick
Knockouts yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's actually like money over hoes or
some [__] on his chest yeah
yeah yeah it's lit dude they just fight
for the right reasons right wait but
like I've worked events like like
working the desk
and like that was one of the like the
guys that we were like
spotlighting yeah like yeah why are you
on the ultimate fighter yeah like how
the [__] did that happen yeah like if he
wins the show like like you said we're
just gonna he's gonna fight three you
guys in a row I think not no he gets
tossed in the mix it's like yo get me
wrong I love a good story but good luck
man but if it's a young Prospect and
they're fighting other young prospects
we can build them they lose one it's not
the end of the world everyone's gonna
graduate towards that young kid in root
form you know it's like the almost the
Patty pimlet effect or or Sean O'Malley
like Shawn O'Malley you can have the
skill set to get tossed in the top 15
his first fight came off damn white
Contender series huge knockout a lot of
hype they've built him the right way and
now arguably top five biggest stars in
the UFC that's the way you should do it
so well and that's it I think that I
think the contender series is a is a gem
I love it there's this kind of it cuts a
lot of the [__] that I don't really
care about you get a quick little a
quick little snapshot of kind of where
they come from
their life behind all this other
fighting stuff and then you get right
into the fights and it's like a free you
know it feels like an extra fight card
every you know every Tuesday I love I
love the contenders that might be what
it is there too is
the daylight Contender series Cuts all
the fat you get the talent those guys go
right in the UFC you kind of don't need
the ultimate fighter
you know it's like yeah I'm a manager if
I'm a manager and a young kid comes up
to he goes hey I got an offer Ultimate
Fighter Dana White Contender series I go
Dana White you don't have to deal with
all the [__] you go right to the UFC
get a good knockout there's going to be
in a house for six weeks yeah proven
Stars you're not fighting things you got
three weeks of contender series guys
right there like you can because I if I
remember right at the beginning when the
contender series was getting ready to
come out
I thought that some of the idea was if
there was a guy that maybe was in the
UFC had some struggles but that maybe
they still believed in him then they
just bumped him back to the contender
series and then brought in a super
experienced guy from the regional scene
and then they just fight it's kind of
like just throw a bone in there and just
make him fight for him
which I love me too I love like kind of
dangling that that fruit in front of
their face and then you just throw it in
and just say [__] fight for boys
are excited too the fights are exciting
because those guys want it the only
bummer is if you have a young Prospect
now obviously he's in the UFC now and I
think he could fight top five is if
you're if you had a young Prospect and
it was the same time Bo nickel was on
the Dana White Contender series
everybody [__] like I told but we came
here I'm like what are you doing dude
like just go straight to UFC you're
stealing all these guys dreams like
these poor kids like you look at BO
nickel maybe I'm just a hardcore dick
rider but I just think with his skill
set what we've seen obviously this next
fight little more challenging for him I
think it's a great test after that man
it's Off to the Races top 15. you like
this stylistically like I think he does
well top five man
in a couple years Bo nickel is going to
be a problem yes
if
if him and David Taylor fight in
different weight classes
oh interesting
you think if
go ahead go ahead
like if him and David Taylor end up in
the same weight class the ball runs into
the similar problems he had wrestling
yeah
bubble's got a little while to he's got
a little bit of a run on David right now
but David's really progressing quickly
yeah he's a beast it's no matter he's
learning really fast I think what makes
bow an outlier we've had big you know
prospects coming to UFC from wrestling
and all credentialed
but for Bo When I See This fluidity of
if it's striking and the way he can mix
it up and it is grappling and I was like
what Bellar he's like Blue Bell I'm like
you need to talk to your coach man
because his transitions the inverted
triangle he's pulling off and all this
[__] that is not blue belt level stuff
here man so I just think the Winston
control yeah man I think his mentality
makes a difference too
um I haven't spent a lot of time around
bro nickel but I've spent a lot of time
around David Taylor and they're they're
two different personalities like Beau
was very abrasive and he just even
watching him wrestle seems very mean yes
like he just like he's one of those guys
that just lives to head snap someone's
face into the mat yeah and David is so
clean technically he's just he's such a
technician I think when he moves over to
fighting I think Beau has the advantage
just mentality wise because sometimes
you just got to be an [__] I agree
and just be meaner than the other guy
and
I think Beau has a little more of that
than David does and and David he still
has he taken any fights yet or he's just
in the process of doing it no he's just
trying to wrestle and and kind of
growing his MMA name or MMA game uh at
the same time which you know his focus
is still the you know he just made the
world team his focus is wrestling in one
more Olympics and then he's going to
make the full transition so he's trying
to do both at the same time
um which is hard because he's always
going to be wrestling's always going to
be his number one right now so it's a
slow it's a very slow progression and
just for the viewers and listeners out
there David Taylor is the one who beat
uh bo nickel
yeah so they were teammates at Penn
State
um I don't I'm not sure if they wrestled
at Penn State at the same time but they
were both Penn State guys
um and they were in the same weight
class wrestling for the worlds and and
to get a world team spot and you know
like not for nothing I think Bo nickel
is a fantastic wrestler especially in
his days at Penn State I'm a huge Legend
a huge division one college wrestling
fan so me too
um I was a bow nickel nut hugger but I
was a bigger David Taylor hugger and
David just wins those matchups it's just
David that's just how it's always the
wrong team yeah he's a Savage yeah it's
just it's just how it is I'm excited I
mean it's over it's not like you know
it's not like you're losing to nobody
you know when I say that people oh he's
[__] on Beau nickel like oh no they
do an Olympic gold medal you know what I
mean to hang your head on I'm excited
for both it goes well for him and
they're giving the ride too I'm excited
for him well I know you're busy dude you
gotta get back to that pool you still
hanging out at the pool how old are the
kiddos
uh my oldest is 11 uh then I have eight
uh an eight-year-old and then my uh uh
uh my six-year-old just turned six today
oh and then uh we have a one and a half
year old damn you're in the thick of it
daddy you are in the thick all daughters
oh all girls
got all girls good for you brother it's
wild good for you man it's wild we'll
let you get back to the b-day party in
the the pool party man I appreciate the
time we're trying to get you on forever
man I'm a big fan I know it I think
you're one of the best Minds in the game
and love to have you back brother
appreciate you man yeah yeah I mean I'd
love to do the the food truck tires too
that always looks like a lot of fun yeah
food truck or flight companion be fun
too but you usually work in those yeah
that'd be a blast yeah we'll figure out
which one you're not on but we'll figure
it out brother appreciate you man
perfect